how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today
we have some pretty awesome doctor
strange in the multiverse of
madness news we have a plot synopsis
that actually gives us quite a bit of
information about doctor strange too
including what doctor strange is going
to be trying to do in the second film
the inclusion of what the synopsis calls
an old friend and of course
the villain and there's a lot to talk
about in the synopsis so let's just jump
right in
the synopsis is coming from the website
backstage who deals a lot with auditions
for movies
they connect actors to auditions and
they get the synopsis for the film that
they're trying to get the actor for
so they are the ones providing the
synopsis for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and apparently
they leaked this some time ago but it
kind of went under the radar i didn't
see it until this weekend
and hopefully this is the first time
that most of you will be hearing it as
well
and it reads as follows after the events
of avengers endgame
doctor strange continues his research on
the time stone
but an old friend turned enemy puts an
end to his plans and causes strange to
unleash
unspeakable evil now there are three
really important
parts to the synopsis one is the time
stone two is the old friend turned enemy
and three is the unspeakable evil
and i'll break down what each one of
these means starting with the time stone
now i've seen a lot of comments saying
that well the time stone is gone how
exactly is he going to be doing research
on the time stone but here's where we
have to think back to what thanos said
in avengers in-game and what the russo
brothers said about the infinity stones
as well
when the avengers found thanos at the
garden natasha asked him
where are the stones and he responded
with gone
reduced to atoms i used the stones to
destroy the stones
where are the stones gone
reduced to atoms you used them two days
ago
i used the stones to destroy the stones
now this is actually very important
phrasing and the russo brothers did
comment on this as well
after avengers in game they were being
interviewed and they were asked about
the infinity stones and their response
was the infinity stones
aren't actually gone thanos just reduced
them to
atoms but they implied that they could
be put back together
and right now if there's any person in
the marvel cinematic universe that has
the potential
to put back together the infinity stones
it's definitely doctor strange
you have to remember that in the first
doctor strange film he did extensive
study on the time stone
and now it sounds like in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness one of
three things are going to happen
when they talk about him doing research
on the time zone it could be one
he's already figured out a way to
somehow use magic and get the atoms of
the time stone and put it back together
now this could happen over the course of
the entire film or it could happen in
the very beginning we're not sure yet
the second option could be he's simply
doing research of
how to put it back together and the
third option is a little bit different
but
wanda could bring back the time stone
after all in the marvel cinematic
universe it does seem like she's already
brought back the mind stone the mind
stone was destroyed with all the other
infinity stones yet
in the one division trailer we see
vision and in his head
is the mind stone and in fact in one
particular scene it looks like
vision even uses the mind stone to
awaken agatha harkness when he touches
her head to wake her up we can clearly
see that it's the power of the mind
stone doing so
in whatever way the time stone comes
back we do know that it's of very big
importance the ancient one explained in
avengers end game that all of the
infinity stones make up the reality of
the universe
and specifically the time stone being
gone is a problem because that was the
only thing keeping dormammu away which
we'll talk about in just a bit
now as far as the old friend turned
enemy is concerned it's
pretty clear that this is going to be
baron mordo he was dr strange's friend
and
a mentor to him in the first doctor
strange film but of course by the end of
the film he turned into a villain and he
began to start hunting down
sorcerers because i see at long last
what's wrong with the world
too many sorcerers so an old friend
turned enemy puts an end to his plans
this is probably going to be mordo
although some people
seem to think that it could be wanda now
of course this is a possibility it's
rumored that doctor strange is going to
be in the one division series so maybe
they could bond in the show
but besides that they really don't know
each other the first time they would
have met
is an avengers in-game and there was a
lot going on now there could have been
some off-screen things happening
after the events of the battle perhaps
wanda and strange could have met at tony
stark's funeral and could have talked
about some sorcery stuff
he maybe could have even invited her to
come down to the sanctum perhaps he
could have even offered to teach her a
thing or two
and there is the possibility that we
could see that happen in the one
division series
so that could happen however it is still
much more likely that this friend turned
enemy
is mordo now the last part of this
synopsis
unspeakable evil is pretty interesting
now this
could tie into the one division series
because there are really three main
options of who this villain could be
really four if you count dormammu but
seeing as how they used him to be the
villain in the first doctor strange film
they most likely won't use him to be the
villain again
yes dormammu is still a threat and yes
he could come back
but marvel will most likely choose a new
villain to make it more exciting so our
first option of who this villain could
be
is nightmare now we know that scott
derrickson and the writers that he had
with him had said they were going to use
nightmare as the main villain but scott
derrickson is no longer directing the
film
sam raimi is now nightmare would still
make a very awesome villain nightmare is
from
the dream dimension and in this dream
dimension he torments human beings who
are brought there during their sleep
nightmare is the first foe that doctor
strange ever went up against in the
comics
he's dealt with him many times and has
even had to partner with him sometimes
as well
now nightmare is run into many different
superheroes over time including
spider-man captain america
ghost rider wolverine the hulk and
squirrel girl so he would definitely be
a very good villain to have
however he doesn't exactly fit the bill
of being an
unleashed villain nightmare is kind of
just there ruling the dream dimension
but however he does
serve under schuma goreth schumagorth is
an
ancient force of chaos an immortal
nearly invincible god-like ruler of
nearly a hundred
alternate universes during earth's
pre-history schumachureth ruled the
world
and demanded human sacrifice until
eventually a time traveling sorcerer
named sais neg
ultimately banished the evil being the
entity eventually returns but is then
imprisoned within a mountain by the
power of the god crumb
shumagorth would eventually try to
return to earth via the mind of the
ancient one but doctor strange is forced
to kill the ancient one in order to
prevent this
and of course there are many many other
times where schuma goreth has threatened
earth and doctor strange has had to take
on this demonic entity now shumagorth is
definitely a
force and an enemy that can be unleashed
and definitely an
enemy worthy of the main villain title
of this film
however there is one other villain that
makes absolutely perfect sense and will
most likely be a villain in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
that is mephisto
now not only does mephisto have a very
large connection to doctor strange but
he also has a very large connection to
the scarlet witch and it's widely
believed that he is going to be a
villain
in the one division series and be
responsible for a lot of things
happening in the comics wanda envisions
kids are actually shards of the demon
mephisto
and he would eventually go on to want
them back and get them back therefore
eliminating wanda and vision's children
well it does look like that's going to
be the case for one division
because we do know that wiccan and speed
their two boys are going to be in the
show this is confirmed we've already
seen them but of course the question
is how does she have these kids are they
in the mcu shards of the demon mephisto
we've seen a lot of crazy things in the
one of vision trailer already and a lot
of things that point to mephisto
actually being in the show which means
since one division is going to lead up
to
and into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and since
wanda is going to be in the movie as
well and play a pretty big role
it would make sense that mephisto as a
villain would be a part of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness as
well and since mephisto primarily is in
the hell dimension which he rules over
he can technically be released into the
main mcu dimension
this would definitely cause a lot of
problems for our master of the mystic
arts and it's actually widely believed
that evan peters who once played
quicksilver in the fox universe will be
playing mephisto in
the mcu now as far as a bonus option is
concerned for the villain there's always
the possibility that it could be wanda
and she could actually go insane
there's no doubt that she's one of the
strongest beings in the entire mcu right
now and if she did lose her mind or get
possessed by somebody
she would definitely be an extremely
powerful villain to deal with
however i don't really think they'll
make her a villain that's why she's a
bonus but let me know what you think
about this plot synopsis and be sure to
let me know
one how you think the time stone comes
back to who you think
the friend turned enemy is and three who
you think the villain is
be sure to let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news like the video if
you enjoyed it and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you